please join me in welcoming back to
Columbia the next mayor of New York Bill
de Blasio sepa class 1987 thank you when
it became apparent during the campaign
for mayor of New York that the candidate
at that point Bill de Blasio was really
interested and focused on the needs of
children but younger children in terms
of preschool pre-k education older kids
in terms of afterschool programs Jeff
Sachs and I thought well this is
somebody who could really lead New York
in a particular way that would be of
great interest to a lot of the people at
Columbia who are in fact focused on the
needs of children and what the needs
being met will mean for the future of
them the kids and the city so once he
prevailed in the election we decided
that we would bring together a body of
experts here to the Columbia campus but
experts from around the city and other
universities and academics and major
policy figures to say what is it that we
can tell the mayor elect so to speak
about what we think the status of
children in New York is and what needs
to be done at the summit that we held we
had very straightforward we had three
panels the first is experts saying this
is the status of children with respect
to early education school programs
health care access and so forth the
second panel is more the science of what
happens when children don't get what
their what their needs are fulfilled and
the third panel is really just to
discuss now what's the road forward and
in the middle of this we had the
mayor-elect himself come and talk in
very specific terms about what he was
trying to do and we had this tremendous
energy bubbling out of this summit of
people experts have been laboring in
these areas for decades finally see in a
new mayor what would got what was going
to be possible we saw this not as an
endpoint but as the beginning of a
process whereby the
depth and breadth of knowledge and
information and groundbreaking research
comes together at Columbia and could end
up being an ongoing resource for the
mayor-elect and then of course the mayor
I today stand before you ready to mount
a strong consistent fight for the things
that will make a difference and that
means free high-quality full-day pre-k
for every child in New York City and it
means after school free after-school
programming for every middle school
child in this city